the numbers on the year from tyler
malley from western and southern the
composite numbers larker really good
he oddly has some pretty wide home road
splits suarez backs up with a couple of
strikes fastball you called for with
elevation gets a swing into this strike
three now paul goldschmidt goldie an old
for last night breaking a 16-game
hitting streak
goldsmith with the drive
how
far
adios
[Applause]
a long one for goldie
goodness gracious goldsmith with home
run number 17. paul deyoung is at his
share of success at the reds expense
swinging to this
book nk's on the inning but a big bomb
from goldschmidt reds in a hole they'll
try to get that run back way leblock
makes his fifth start since leaving the
bullpen changing those roles with john
gant move back to the bullpen leblanc
and the rotation
swing and a mess and a strikeout way the
block is first of the night in the first
out here in the bottom of the first 274
five homers 25 knocked in for stevenson
and that one to the opposite gap
splashes on down
india slows bobbled by carlson late
break by india carlson fires cut off at
second india easily claims third now the
reds have runners at the corners with
only one out and here's joey votto
bottom hammers it fair
indian jogs hold stevenson through
second
carlson just now gets to the ball
furious windmill for stevenson throw in
relay to the plane no shot
score standing a two-run double pummeled
by bono and the red zombie board 2-1
aquino has hit 116 against cardinal
pitching
swaying and a miss
so three strikeouts in the inning
to go along with three hits including a
double that plates two two one after one
harrison bader leading off for the
cardinals who trailed two to one
vader
left field and this game is tied
solo home run harrison bader number
seven and we're tied two-two
don't let a fastball sneak by right
tyler mally throws something there in
the zone put a good swing on it top of
the order and the switch hitting carlson
who struck out swinging
swing of the miss struck him out third k
for mali two at the expense of carlson
naquin has done well against the
cardinals this year
first walk of the night goes to naquin
to begin the home second mike schilt is
coming out of the
cardinals dugout once word
with buckner was that actually a 3-2
pitch that walked naked you see
the smile from naquin it looks like yes
he's going to have to grab his bat and
go back to the dish
3-2 is hit into the shift and the young
is there so naquin goes from a lead off
walk to a ground out now jonathan india
got him so that's four strikeouts in two
innings for the cardinals starter
tonight aquin thought he walked his
first time up
[Applause]
out to deep left oh what a catch up
against the wall the goal glover tyler
o'neal
leblanc loves it and that's out number
one
tyler just made that play look like it
was routine it was anything but
farmers he bats with nobody on and one
out
kyle farmer
goes fairly vertical
out of here for a home run
leblanc trying to sneak a fastball in
that ball definitely clearing the wall
tyler stevenson singled and then also
grounded out to short 3-2
fly ball to center
plenty of room bader under it and puts
it away reds will strand a pair but they
pick up a homer off the bat of farmer
the bases are loaded with one out the
reds are leading it three to two payoff
swing and a miss fastball away strikes
him out that's a huge second out and now
paul de young struck him out
back-to-back strikeouts leave him full
cardinals now have the tying run as we
play here in the sixth inning at second
base with nobody out
and the 1-0 is smacked the other way for
a base hit
they'll hold up vader and the first two
have reached edmond the single to left
andrew kisner has a chance to double his
rbi total if he can get a base hit here
kisner with a fly ball into right center
at the wall and it's over aquino
and one hops over the wall
aquino had a beat on it couldn't come up
with it and andrew kisner delivers and
two runs will score and the cardinals
have regained the lead
2-2 and a base hit by sosa kisner is
held up at third runners at the corners
four consecutive hits for the redbirds
here at the top of the sixth dylan
carlson is the batter
carlson with the drive out to deep right
and the catch is made by aquino
tagging up kisner
and he will score
alejo lopez right-handed batter
and lopez hits a fly ball into shallow
ride carlson yes the sliding catch dylan
carlson in shallow right field there's
that defense again of the cardinals it
just keeps showing up doesn't it two
ball two strike count vader windmills
the bat and santiago for the play swing
and a mess he struck him out
that's how you did and stanion got after
it right there after coming in and
turning a 2-0 down strike one strike two
strike three bugs bunny back for the
dugout one down and now tommy edmond
payoff
called strike three
96 on the block away
andrew kisner
got a couple of hits today came into the
ball game hitting at 178. here's a line
driving to right and look at aquino he
makes the play but i tell you what all
eyes are on tony santiago as he comes on
with a 2-0 count
punches out hater punches out edmond he
gets kissner and no run scored here's a
eugenio suarez time to come to the party
hard ground ball fair stevenson scores
final through second suarez shoots up to
second
rbi double a eugenio
[Applause]
aquino one for three tonight
big and bad here all the way to the
backstop
oh my goodness that will score votto and
folks we are tied at five a piece and
the 1-0 to aquino the infield drawn in
for st louis
makino lifts a fly ball into right
carlson with the catch
the throw to the plate it's there in
time and got him
what a strong throw dylan carlson a
bullet from right and it turns into a
double play the bases are loaded for
tyler stevenson
stevenson slugs it to center
baiter makes the catch farmer tags it
third the throw into the play
a slide save
set fly rbi tyler stevenson reds lead
6'5
and the last man standing is not yadi
molina he remains on the bench it's
starting pitcher adam wainwright a
career 191 bad with 10 home runs
swinging in a mess he struck him
a perfect ninth for henry
and the reds have won five in a row
against